and live good afternoon good morning
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world it's freezing
here it's so cold what's the
temperature um it's minus two ah minus
two yeah minus two I don't know what
that is in Fahrenheit mate so you have
to no that's fine that's sounds cold so
um it's well it's it's
freezing it's oh my thing says I'm going
to it's going to
snow okay gon get snow I'm gonna be
Christmas decorations up today I'm gonna
be so
happy says it's snowing now it's not no
stupid phone anyway Mac from the um
Adventure Playground I forget what
you well the general thing is the
forever Adventure Network fan F but as
it relates to us there's the mcgyver
podcast and the MacGyver sg1 audio
Series so excellent well links to all of
your stuff is in the description so
please go and check it out and you I
know you put a crap load of work into
what you do I really everybody go and
have a look
captain man is in not seen you for ages
sir how are you as Sarah's in K's in
Dave is in guys we are just oh marks in
30 minute Doctor Who warning new Doctor
Who episode in 29 minutes is it I still
have to watch the previous one I'm still
trying to watch the previous one we
don't have Disney plus and it's killing
me disappointing every day I go on I'm
like can I watch it now
no okay you know I did not know that was
today I thought it was next week so we
might should have done this probably a
little bit earlier because everyone's
gonna what go through uh first chapter's
in Laura's in hey hey hey uh Mark just
quick one are you hoping for a better
episode than we got the first one the
first one do you know how a lot of
people shout woke at things and I go I
hate the word woke the first episode is
quite
woke I'm just thrilled to see David
Tenant he can do anything and I'm gonna
watch it you know yeah David tenant's
awesome in brain pain and Andrew how you
John Campbell how you do sir um it just
seemed to me that um when you watch it
obviously there's been a lot of
controversy about them making doctor a
girl um and and they just seemed to me
that they were very much wanted to make
the point that it's fine and that that
it's okay and I'm just like they just
went on it a bit too much um you know I
always said that these things I I think
shows should have an agenda they should
have you know lism they should you know
um teach us something maybe right um
have morals but you don't have to hit
them with a sledgehammer yeah you don't
have to go on and on and on about it the
entire episode yeah um it there should
be a story to it and they just
right right well that's the the CW shows
got ruined because they forgot oh wait
we're supposed to be doing a superh hero
show about this character and then she
gets she or he whoever whatever show you
pick got shoved to the back because and
I had some like you I had some Insider
info uh of the very open Agenda they
they said no we this is a show where
we're trying to have all minorities
everybody be a minority which on the
surface sounds okay until you forget
your plot and yeah needless to say
there's no more CW so I am I don't care
about
um a show having an agenda I don't care
a show coming on and going right this is
going to be about racism because I'm
very angry about racism so I'm gonna
have a show about racism um and if it's
a Sci-Fi show then it like great because
we can use the metaphor of anything to
make our point but we can still make an
interesting story because that's what
sci-fi's always been it's always been
about that every robot ever in every
sci-fi is about either slavery or
Freedom or or the imagined Freedom or
whatever Androids and sci-fi that's why
they're there um but I you've got to do
a story as well right and you you did a
video the other day that said it very
well I mean you you yeah I I for me I
always say I want equal I want
representation that's great but I want
equality and it seems like in the last
few years since a certain person became
president the pendulum had to swing so
far the other way to try and compensate
for all the negativity that was brought
that it went too far so now I'm thinking
it's starting to get more you know into
this area remember the 90s the the term
politically correct came about and I was
so happy to see that go away because it
became everything oh everything offends
everybody all the time and then last
couple years it came back and oh God so
now we seem it seems to be going more
equal I think the me too movement was
when I think Trump getting into power
that might have had something to do with
it oh I said the t-
word um I think it was more the me too
movement and um and and don't got be
wrong the me too movement had to happen
because Hollywood needed a clear out
yeah it was you know it was way too many
men in way too much power and I'm sorry
but if you get a fat ugly guy in Power
and beautiful women desperately want you
know to get in your movie a lot of men
are going to take advantage of that
horrible for a century um so I mean it
had to happen but then I think a lot of
studios and executives are now so
stressed about being called any IST
racist massive over a correction yeah
because the people who originally were
trying to fight the good fight well then
you have other people coming off from
the side going oo I could I can accuse
somebody of doing something that maybe
they didn't do but it gets them out
they're out and now you tarnished the
good will you know woke used to be a
good thing it meant meant like you you
know I think you said in your video it
meant awake and aware and but then you
know some guy or girl or whoever comes
along and tarnishes is the
the you
know
intent yeah yeah exactly um I I think it
got Twisted by like Fox News and people
they sort of you know
how
um sort of the some minorities took you
can't say the NW and I'm not going to
because it would actually it's it's
that's probably the only real swear word
left um but that was reappropriated by
black people and going you it's not
going to be an insult word we're going
to take it back back and I think a lot
of like Bal tattooed [__] when
you're not going to have that word then
we'll take it back and started using it
and I'm
like but I would just say things should
be awake I like I like that when our TV
shows are awake well kindness I mean
everything should be it's not really not
that difficult it it really isn't hard
to be nice to people you know and KN
when to say you're wrong
boring honestly if if I stand here and
just add go at you for 45 minutes um we'
probably get more
views right
right go at them I always think about
what you know what did you put into the
world today there's people who go on the
internet and say horrible horrible
things or bad mouth whatever okay that
was your contribution today you lost
that you know you put bad into the world
yeah I'm not drinking bu light though
I'm I'm getting mocked for drinking
Budweiser I like Budweiser I love you
Americans you you gave me alcohol that I
like I was drinking Co light and I
got
yeah grief I don't drink so I just have
water you know I've I've got children so
I drink quite a lot
yeah I'm a Manchester United fan so I
drink even more did I tell you my kids
are 14 and 11 and we were in church one
time when they were little and you know
we taught them shut up you're in church
be respectful understand where you are
blah blah BL
so they know that and they've always
been good kids
and as we're getting out of church this
nice little old lady who was sitting in
front of us the whole time we're you
know so we're turned we're walking out
she Taps me on the shoulder and she goes
your children are so sweet they're so
well behaved and I said well beatings
help and she
went you know my son who God knows how
big he was at the time lost it he
thought that was he talks about it to
this day yeah you
know I was um a manager for years and um
in Social care and um and this I I rule
with an Iron Fist and everyone should
like laugh at me I do I no no you don't
um but yeah I think um I would never hit
a child unless he deserved it or it was
funny in which case I think it's
fine
but but yeah as long as it's as long as
this like makes you chuckle
afterwards well you know one of the
funniest things for me is watching those
videos where the unexpected happens
where you see someone in like a um oh
what like a mascot suit with that face
that doesn't change and they fall off a
stage that cracks me up that I lose it
because the whole time they're going you
know no matter what the terror is inside
they're still like hey boom so you like
that is funny it just is and you don't
want anyone to get like seriously you
know sometimes I these videos on like
YouTube on Tik Tok now and it's like a
horrible Chira and he's like Jesus
Christ did I just watch like four people
die right that's not you know like
that's not funny but when we get like
the um we called what was the show over
here you know like those blooper things
where people send in the funniest videos
is what we have yeah um so I mean those
sort of things are because they Norm
have to say like nobody was hurt and
they go oh I can laugh then because it
looked like he was killed but nobody was
hurt some guy comes coming off with oh
it's even better when somebody like does
skateboarding thing and trying to be
cool and there's like a pole and they
goes crack and like I'm laughing about
that for a month there was a show they
took it off the air but it was one of
those MTV shows and it was called like
scarred or something like that yeah and
and it was all about these idiots and I
laughed whether they got hurt and it
they all got hurt they all broke a bone
they all and they show it uh but it was
all these idiots who are trying to be
cool I'm going to skateboard down this
railing yeah and they yeah dude they
recording it and of course tragedy
ensues I laugh hysterically because you
idiots did it to yourself it wasn't like
you accidentally you know fell off the
stage you threw yourself into a wood
chipper what did you think was gonna
happen yeah I don't remember seeing on I
went from I can't remember where I was
going now but I got to the train station
and there was a bus service on so we
were all like oh God they were you know
they were fixing the so so I came for a
train because I didn't want to drive and
then guess what I'm driving in a massive
vehicle it's really slow and was like
brilliant so but the bus pulled up and
obviously everybody wanted to get like
good seats so this woman it was very
pretty dressed really nicely but had
really high heels and it was a really
cold day so it was all icy so she tried
to run for it um to get get to the bus
first
T over and I then thought it was funny
to step over and go down in front and
keep walking and she was so mad she was
like okay pH you didn't have to take the
piss you didn't have to take the piss
like of course I did she's embarrassed
she's embarrassed and you know and
you're laughing basically laughing at
her so you know she doesn't know what
else to do I'm taking it out on you you
know well you shouldn't have tried to
get it into the front and should just
calmly walked to the bus like everybody
else
IID to run for it I avoid so much
trouble by just going you know what if
it's that important to you go ahead you
can have the window seat or whatever it
is you know whether I want it or not but
once you become a parent you're you're
not as eager to get
into the Hostile situation because
things escalate like that when they when
they shouldn't you know so I just go
just as I'm driving you stupid idiot you
st I'm not I'm not going to roll up next
to them and tell them that because now
you've started trouble you got you know
vent it and then let it go because then
I think about the kids in the back oh
here's a good one on that note years ago
I have both kids very small in the back
seat I'm taking them to my parents
before I go to
work I'm I was next to this dump truck
that was driving down the road I had to
go this way to go to the gas station so
I went in front of him had to put on the
brakes for the oncoming traffic as I
turn and get Park to get gas the dump
truck stops and this guy gets out and
he's ticked oh because I to be fair I
did mess up I I had him use his brakes
he has to use air breaks you know God
forbid it didn't stop in time so he's
ticked got it I was wrong so he gets out
he goes you dumb stupid blankety
blanketed and I yell over him H yeah all
right I'm sorry dude I my fault I'm
yes okay you're right I'm
sorry right that was the mature thing to
do but it wasn't enough this guy because
he's like you're a
d okay got you thank you and I start
getting gas and he keeps going and I go
okay that's
enough that's enough I'm done bye now he
thinks oh yeah he starts rolling up his
sleeves and he's walking across traffic
to come at me now I look in the car and
I got two little kids in a car seat
I don't I'm not worried about this guy
I'll I and that's not ego I I know what
I'm doing and if I have to drop him I
will but I don't want that because
there's cameras and now you have a
lawsuit and I got kids here so I try one
last thing I go hey I said I was
sorry that's it I can't give you
anything else I was wrong you were right
get in your truck and drive
away I had nothing else so he
goes
all right he gets in
hiss away you I think God Dodge that I
learned the way of avoiding a fight um
the easiest way I was um I was staying
at 8 years ago and um we heard breaking
window and there had been a load of um
burglar in the area so we heard a window
break and we were like I think I think
we been broken into and M glender he
stood up on right took off his trousers
and started to take his pants off and I
like what the [__] are you doing I just
like if he's breaking in nobody's going
to try and stab me if I'm butt naked are
they and went downstairs but naked right
and I was thinking that he's lost his
mind then I'm thinking now if I'm the
burglar and this butt necked guy comes
down going what are you doing I ain't
getting involved in that fight I'm going
so I was actually thinking he's a genius
that's actually so if ever know anybody
starts with me I'm just I start taking
clothes off that's
but I'm fighting
naked because no bloke is g to start
with like oh hands keep it away I'm good
thanks don't need that but I I was I
went through um a divorce years ago and
I went I had a uh an angry face we'll
put it that way and I was really pissed
off and the whole world was against me
and um and I uh I was driving to my job
and this Taxi driver there's just like
it's like an island right and it's like
three lanes but it's like it's one of
those things that goes two three two
three all the way around so you like
have to feed in so as you go off then
you have to come across and you know
what I mean it's like it it moves you
over sure so this guy he tried to cut
the inside of me and then go across
three lanes to shoot down and he and I
was like and he pipped but I cut him
over because I was following the moving
over thing like he's supposed to so
he's and got me so I like I did nothing
wrong so my little angry thing came out
he drove down to the train station so I
pulled up next to him got out and start
really like having a go at him you and
um but I I pulled his um windscreen
wiper up like I was going to rip it off
or
something that was to the point that I
realized the horrific mistake I'd made
and for one it's really angry it's
really you know it's like it's I I okay
fair enough he pipped his horn there's
really no need to get violent at it what
was I actually going to do if this guy
got out was like what I going to do
punch him and end up in the jail cell
you know that what was actually so I
just went very English B I'm I'm so
sorry and I
think having a terrible day I was like
but I just went I went full Hugh Grant
like mode terribly sorry I what I was
thinking then as I walked away I sort of
went oh he
lord well good for you that you stopped
yourself you know unfortunately you know
people are too too quick now to to swing
at somebody over stupid crap too like
there's a show H it caught one of those
caught on camera things and you can
watch a half hour it's there's one
called Neighbor Wars there's like
traffic Wars now they have holiday Wars
and it's basically you know neighbors
fighting with each other and you think
it's it's so not worth it one of the
shows on the crime channel is Fear Thy
Neighbor and you'd be amazed at the
things that that that set people off to
to now have a war with their neighbor
I'm gonna do this there you go actually
God are you looking at my I had one of
them show up a month ago at my house and
I I I I'm Catholic you're not converting
me thank you uh you know and I don't I
don't want to be rude because again even
though they're a pest they're human
beings and I don't want to just slam my
door on them and so I kind of have fun
with it I open the the door and they're
like oh because they didn't expect
anybody to answer I open door I said hi
what what what do you two need and
they're all with the white shirts and
the black tie and you know and they got
their book and everything and and what
what do you need and they go oh
uh okay
um we're we're from the church of blah
blah blah blah blah and oh yeah yeah
okay yeah I'm Catholic that's my church
right over there see the steeple yeah
however I don't here's an idea you're
looking for to talk to you need to go
down about five houses on the left see
that yellow house yeah they would love
to hear from you oh okay and they think
thank you thank you very much sir nah my
pleasure happy to help have a great day
they leave I close the door my wife goes
who did you just send them to I don't
know the neighbor down do we know them
no no we
don't the next barbecue either are they
but can you picture them going opening
the door going hi your neighbor down
there said you'd love to talk to us
which one you know that I we don't know
that the one with a white door
yeah um I I I made the mistake I keep
trying to think I can convert Jehovah's
Witnesses it's a terrible thing they
knock on my door and I I will quite
happily chat to him I find other
people's view points fascinating um but
there are certain things that you just
got no come on there there's a black and
white truth to this and I'm look say
look Evolution there's this um Lake in
uh in Canada and um when they were
trying to find the Northwest route you
know when we were exploring and trying
to find a trade route through through
the Northwest Canada they found this
Lake because what they would do each
year they would just go a little bit
further sort of thing and then the ice
had come and they'd have to back up so
they get to this Lake and they go right
we're g to dump a load of goopies in
this in this Lake um this this fish and
then um when we come next next year
we'll fish the lake and we've got some
food yum yum yum now there's about 20
different types of guppy in this Lake
right because they've evolved so there's
little Guppies that are the surface and
they they're thing but they've become
now distinct variants of the same fish
there's this big ugly one that goes
right down to the bottom and it eats the
thing so I'm telling the Jehovah's
Witnesses and that's they go that's very
interesting no evolution is nonsense
gods did it 6,000 like no I am giving
you and like a fact you could go and
fish the damn thing if you wanted to
it's not it's not opinion it's black and
white fact right and they just like no
God okay well it it doesn't have to be
one or the other you know you can kind
of like convert your own thinking and
still understand a higher power but you
do whatever you gotta do um James yeah
we will talk about sci-fi at some point
we're going to talk about the Fallout
trailer in minute but this is a hangout
video we'll talk about whatever we want
um so guys actually in the comments if
you want to throw in any questions or
some or stuff you want us to talk about
we're happy to but this is just us
hanging out having a chat no subject
enjoying our companies enjoying yeah
well like if you don't want to watch it
don't to watch it but yeah we will not
talk about Star Trek um even though we
could talk about Star Trek what did I
want to talk about Star Trek section
31's going in production
what is that that uh it's got in
production filming starts in
January um so the Michelle yo movie oh
really it's only filming for like eight
weeks though which is a bit concerning
it's a really short production period
what's the
premise uh well it's a bit weird because
the last time we saw Michelle Yo's
character Zio she was going through um
the portal of something I forget what
it's called the big donut thing that was
in the original series as well oh okay
World of
Tomorrow guardian of Tomorrow something
like that um and then um she's she
stepped through that and that's all we
know and then the but the film's called
section 31 so it's going to be about
section 31 but we don't know how but
Michelle Yo's character Mich in Zio is
just and somebody said to me goes um if
if you're asked what your favorite thing
about Star Trek Discovery is you must
say the character is your show played by
Michelle yo and I'm like no the question
is what is the only good thing about
Star Trek Discovery I just
started I started the second season I
got through one and then I started to
watch strange new worlds and uh my buddy
Nate said oh yeah they reference stuff
that happens in season two of Discovery
so you might want to watch Discovery two
before you get into strange new
worlds oh crap okay no they don't really
they mention once or twice but not
really you can just watch Str world it's
not it's not thing um if you've watched
the original series it helps if you
watch strange new worlds but um the
thing is in well if you start to watch
season two Discovery then you know that
Pike is in in it sure um and it explains
a few things like how suddenly Spock's
got a sister which is fine sure screw
Canon it's for it's for Cannon's for
losers um so or you know or things that
have been like disussed before
loser um I sense the cynic in you yeah I
hate Discovery it's it's the worst Star
Trek show I've tried tried so hard to
watch it um I've seen to um guy from the
shuttle pod show and he was chatting
he's like you must watch it it gets
better and I'm like now I've watched it
I messaged in Mark a couple weeks ago
I'm like no it doesn't you lied to me um
and if I ever meet you I'm going to
punch you in your stupid face because
this J doesn't get any better it gets
worse W they went into the 32nd century
and I've got all the new and I love a
spaceship I'm like oh new spaceships I'm
like oh spaceship porn um and even
that's
crap well I watched the first two
seasons of peard and then everybody's
going you have to see the third season
because I know the the band gets back
together yay and I'm all for
that uh however when that came out I had
like three episodes of season two left
and somebody online was like no just
drop the drop the second season and go
right to season three yeah and I'll tell
you I wouldn't call myself a treky or a
Star Wars person yet I watch them like
you know what I mean it's not part of my
DNA the way Stargate is but yeah I do
appreciate good quality stuff and theard
season one and Season Two started good
but you could kind of feel them drag
stuff yeah like I went okay this should
have been this doesn't seem to go where
I was expecting it to go and it's a lot
of offshoots like very long time to get
there as well yeah that's what I'm say
was three episodes stretched into 10
thank you that's exactly right that's
exactly how I felt I'm like huh I'm
bored with this and I'm only watching it
because I like to be a completist and
finish what I start I don't like to drop
something if I drop
something I got really bad yeah yeah and
I've really tried you know like you you
sent I'm always the next episode might
be better and it and it just was season
two though of Picard particularly the
first episode was brilliant so good so
good and then um it just wasn't no and
then um perfectly yeah just we detailed
red dwarf's coming back as well um it's
going to be a complete reboot apparently
well that's the plan at the moment if
the British people I don't know how much
red dwarf we seen in America but Nick
sorry is it Nick
Frost no no okay I'm thinking of
something else Frost had a great series
that I loved and I only saw like a
handful of episodes this is um four
complete losers on a spaceship the minor
spaceship and then the he's the kryon is
a robot and rim is a hologram is a
complete bell end and and Cat is a
evolved um there's the kitty cat that
was basically left the ship and it
evolved into a whole species and the cat
just ow that's mine and that's mine and
going around and just I'm going to eat
you little fishy it's just it's it's
awesome but um I'll check the first five
or six seasons are hilarious then it
just went off a
cliff the original Creator is trying to
make a new series you know I don't know
if we talked about it before but I'm at
a point
where uh there's so much to
see but yet so little that I think is
necessarily worth my time because
there's a lot of critically acclaimed
shows out there and they're brilliantly
written and they're brilliantly acted
but there's a negativity to it like like
you sent me the boys trailer well I
watched two seasons of the boys I had
I'm a comic book guy I didn't read the
book but I because I knew what it was
and the show does capture it
perfectly which is why I can't watch it
anymore I love I love the different I
love the different angle of a superhero
trope great but what you just said it's
just foul for the sake of being foul and
I'm not six learning new curse words so
I don't it's not for me you know what I
mean it's it's a lot of that like look
at what we did bet you never thought a
superhero do this not for me I don't I
loved the first season of the boys it
was probably my favorite show when it
came out because it was so different
right um and the second season was okay
and I I didn't enjoy as much of the
first because I I was saying to somebody
about um actually think we talked about
on the live with the new series genv it
starts straight away at 100 miles an
hour it's it's up here straight away and
that's that's my only problem with the
boys I think even in the first episode
of the first season it's it's here
straight away but the problem is you've
got nowhere to go you can't shock me
anymore than that without going into
like well it got vulgar for me it's like
a little guy in another guy's
and I'm just like I don't want to watch
this right right I don't feel good when
it's like when I watch a show I want to
be either happy content or inspired and
a lot of these shows that are out now
and I could go through a list but it's
been going on for 10 15 years now where
yeah they're great they're brilliantly
written but the overall feeling when
it's over is oh I have to root for a bad
guy right against a bad guy well I don't
like that you know here we go here's a
subject for us because I did a video in
the week talking about um how everyone
copied Babylon 5 right but I did say in
the video I'm using the word copied is a
bit it's a bit click baity really um I
think inspiration I don't think these
people stole off each other and I didn't
talk about the plagiarism claims do you
know do you know about this when Babylon
5 um was
released yeah well jmss got really angry
right so year before or two years before
Babylon 5 came out he pitched Babylon 5
to Paramount and they they said no
thanks um so then he pitched a warden
Brothers they went yeah yeah yeah let's
do it and did babyon 5 they did the
movie and they came out the first season
first episode of DS9 the first
season I want to say
93 97 whatever year it was anyway that
came out a couple of weeks after that
the TV movie for babyon 5 came out but
then a year after that the f season of
babon 5 came out um and obviously
there's a lot of similarities between d
space now now on the video I didn't
bring this up because it's complicated
so I just left it I ignored it
completely I got a few comments going
you don't know anything I'm like okay
whatever of course to the course I don't
know about one of the biggest
controversies in sci-fi for the good
sake but anyway
um but JMS basically has has since
repeatedly said more than once that um
they got they got on really well with
the cast and crew of d space 9
afterwards um but there are a lot of
similarities but the big thing is that
that even jesa sort of said and other
people
said when they decided they were going
to do a dpace 9 series when they said
they were going to do a spin-off of TNG
when it was doing really popular it was
around season uh three of TNG it was a
couple of years it was even before um
babon 5 had been pitched and when they
said when they then asked for people
people to start pitching ideas and
things and banon Barger um Brandon
Barger and pitched this deep space IR
idea but they were told as the only
pitch brief was it cannot be based
aboard a Starship it can't be another
Starship show because we've got tngg is
still going to be running so we've got
to so it's got to be something different
it's got to be fundamentally different
and the point is like if you basically
go you're doing a Star Trek show but it
cannot be a board of Starship really
what options have you got left
so I mean JMS just really didn't want
his Babylon 5 to be seen as like Star
Trek's poor son so he did kick off but
there was never any legal action um and
there's a lot of rumors to say that
actually jmss had been it had been
settled out of court and then he put the
money back into Babylon 5 and it's not
true there's no evidence to say that it
was ever paid any money um or any Court
action was ever started because he
couldn't have anyway there was no legal
basis for them you can I if I show you a
script and then you write a script
that's a bit similar it's not plagiarism
right right it's it's inspirational sure
so so so yeah I specifically didn't talk
about it in this video because it's a
really topic it would you would have had
to spin off and it's a 45 minute video
on its own right oh my God I got so many
comments on it just like so I just
wanted to try to th I did try to tell
people they're like look it's because it
there's lot there's more rumor than fact
there's as much rumor as fact sorry on
this on this topic and a lot of people's
opinions and but it's complicated but
every show has been inspired by some
sure oh absolutely I mean you you I the
shows that I know so well I can go oh
okay so they're clearly doing a riff on
whatever you know that's great because
you're not hiding it you're not you're
saying no no no we we love this thing
too here's our version of it h wink wink
nudge nudge yeah okay but you know then
there are those who would rip it off but
I don't see that so often really and
you've got I mean I mean we're not
Thomas Edison here we're not like
blatantly copying everyone else's work
are we we're um you know but plagiarism
is exactly copying like John says and
that's not what happened but they might
have been some
inspiration and the thing is though I my
argument in it was Babylon 5 was
one of those shows that was um different
H and nothing else had been quite done
like before and I can see a lot of
creators would watch Pon 5 and go God
man that's good that's I love how
they're doing this battle sequence blah
blah blah I always hear that my since it
came out my buddy Scott Tipton uh we
just did a never gets old podcast uh
episode where we do one of these we're
we're talking for three and a half hours
just and and whatever comes to mind
we're talking about it well he writes
the Star Trek comics and the Doctor Who
comics well he's always after me you got
to watch Babylon 5 you got to watch
Babylon five and I tried I watched
whatever I'm thinking it was the
miniseries but the problem that I'm
having with it
is I think I started it at the wrong
spot because if you go on the internet
you say what's the order of Babylon 5
well they do they did prequel movies and
the one I saw was the one of the guys
older and he's talking to his grandkids
he goes here's a story to tell and it's
a flashback yeah so I watched it I'm
like okay I see the is it yeah
um I would guess because you already
knew what you were into and I'm going I
I don't I don't know who these guys are
chronologically just watch it in the
order it was made just watch the series
the order is made and then watch the TV
movies afterwards um The Call to Arms is
brilliant though because we know there's
this whole thing with the meari war
against Earth and it's gets talked about
a lot in the Babylon 5 series because
that's it's the Fallout afterwards that
the series is set okay so it gets talked
about a lot and it gets talked about how
Sheridan's character was um one of the
only people to ever defeat the mearian
battle and then in the movie we get to
see it okay so you've got five years of
sort of like being teased this and then
they did the movie this is like
yeah see and I would love that if I
watched this from the first episode on I
think the first episode I thought was
the first episode starts in a bar where
two people are
like at each
other is that right am I am I yeah I
think so yeah because I started to watch
it I went I think I missed an EP I think
I I don't think I'm watching the right
thing and I got out of it and that's
when I did that miniseries do Babylon 5
watch it from the beginning even though
the first season is isn't great okay um
because it's it's it's a genre defining
season a show and then you watch that
then and you think about a lot of sci-fi
that's come after it and you be like
yeah I think a lot of people like Ronald
Mo and people like that watched Babylon
5 sure and liked it sort thing it's got
no money they had no money it's it's a
very low budget series um but that adds
a lot to its charm to be honest um
and it's there's so many things in there
there's loads of things with
spirituality and things like this as
well that it's just so
thought-provoking um but the whole
premise of the series is this the shadow
War
um and it is it is finalized in such a
beautiful way that I'm not going to
spoil for you but it is not what you
expect okay um and there's this whole
thing about children and parents and as
as a parent I know you you know you got
to let go of your kids at one point and
that's some big sort of
like the way they talk about I don't
want to because honestly it's it's it's
marvelous but the first season isn't
great but as soon as um Sheridan rocks
up it gets a lot better you remind me of
when I'm trying to
explain to people why they need to watch
sg1 like people who haven't watched s
and I'm like first of all shame on you
second of all buckle up but I always
tell them listen the first season is a
setup season it's them going through the
gate dealing with whatever but then by
the end it's very star treky then they
go back home the end and I remember
watching it and going boy this better
change because as much as I love RDA
they got to do something a little more
and by the end of the first season you
go oh okay you know with the with the
mirror you're like okay from that
episode on it it goes now that you you
understand it we're hitting you and then
second season on they're not a team
anymore they're a family you know the
moment Daniel comes back and they
thought he was dead and Jack hugs him
and calls him Space Monkey you
go okay now they're family and you feel
that from the second season on but I
have to warn whoever starts I go when
you start watching this don't think you
you you've seen everything don't think
you go all right I get what star Gate's
about no you don't so that the way you
explained that reminds me of myself in
that way I've been watching um sg1 again
recently yeah and I tell you what that
show the first few the first probably 15
episodes I don't I I I try not to swear
very often but God this [__] there's so
many Bad episodes in that first half of
season but I I try to say to people all
the
time you tell me a single show that was
brilliant straight away right that went
on to then actually be a successful show
because people always go well lost the
first season of lost go yeah look where
that ended up that was one of those
shows they had a brilliant IDE and they
had no freaking clue where they were
going with it um and then they you know
and and they showing the kids that right
now on season one have lost well the
first season is
phenomenal I loved it all the way
through but again I was able to I I
everybody was complaining that you
didn't wrap everything up you didn't
tell us what about creation of the smoke
creature and blah blah blah blah and I
just went okay I got it I understand
your point we live in that world where
you get info dump and you're G to find
out everything I just kind of went it's
a mystery you're on a mystical Island
and you it wrapped it up as best they
did and I'm like I accept it as long as
they didn't just you know the nothing
made sense ever oh no it it what what
lost ended up doing was we're answering
this but now that opens up this and I
think people always answer always answer
a question people got sick of the new
mystery and I think like well to each
their own and but I think the SG won the
first few season the first there there
were a lot of episodes in the first
season because they they're setting a
lot of things up and they didn't really
know what they were doing and they also
were trying to connect it so much to the
movie if you notice they in the first
five episodes maybe more they're
constantly playing the same soundtrack
type of thing from the movie so that way
you go oh if you saw the movie this is
going to feel like it's just that and
then eventually they got comfortable
enough to go all right cut the music
let's have a scene with them just
talking yeah remember I remember as a
matter of fact one of the friends who
has no patience to try anything she said
I kind of watched I kind of watched the
first three
episodes and I don't know it feels very
militaristic I they're in the Air Force
genius I mean if if that what threw you
you don't deserve Stargate get out don't
watch it I don't want you to watch it
move on it's just it's all very watch
there's a brilliant movie called A Few
Good Men go watch out oh no no you're
not
gonna um top no no over the river quiet
no don't no no can't watch that unless
she really loves whistling
um I know is that is that
the um but yeah and that's a strange
thing but it's just one of those shows
obviously we watched it first time
around when it was brand new but you
watch it back now and I try and get
people into it um yeah you do have to
sort of push through but Star Trek the
Next Generation is still considered one
to be one of the most
successful sci-fi shows you know in the
last 30 years sort of thing the first
season is rubbish well the first I I my
wife who before I introduced her to
Stargate was Star Trek next Generation
was her show and yeah there you go the
Great Escape um and she said you know it
doesn't really pick up until the third
season next Generation once they get rid
of Tasha yard then it really and I'm
like all right okay I don't know I don't
think that's the third season I think
it's halfway through the second isn't it
okay well again I think she's saying
once she's gone the third season is
like um all of a sudden Jordi lege
becomes um gets an engineering
qualification and becomes head of
engineering in he's a [__] pilot
before that but anyway and they actually
put a cling on in charge of
security
duh yeah also Wesley get rid of freaking
Wesley nobody even Wesley didn't like
Wesley no
no I made the mistake of actually
putting sh up Wesley on her will
week me
immediately but I thought it was really
funny because he'd said something um
about having a go at people um for not
saying shut up Wesley so obviously then
a million people went shut up Wesley
immediately and he just starts blocking
them one by one um and then um he put
something about um basically that he's
sick of it and he he doesn't want to
have to block anyone else so I
immediately put shut up Wesley and the
next line and he blocked me I thought
been quite you said you just said you
weren't gonna said you wouldn't do
it um but but yeah I'm like say I'm
sorry but you're just going to there
there's a million memes you're gonna
have to put up with that
will it's part of the world you know
yeah I love will weaton he's a great guy
and he's he seems really funny and I
watch him a lot of interviews and and he
seems genuine and he's a massive Star
Trek sci-fi nerd which you gotta love
but Wesley crush his character was a
bell end and it's just it was really
irritating and they
turned the ACT I watched the thing the
documentary thing I think it's on
YouTube where they talk about the
creation of of Star Trek and they go all
the way through next generation and you
know and to hear about the crap that
they all went through you're like wow
guys you're just making a TV show relax
you know like R would say we're not
curing cancer we're just trying to
provide entertainment let's relax
unclench know right you like Stargate
right who are you talking to me yeah you
like Stargate so let's see
um smidge this argument with
Ralph okay let's God bless you Ralph
you're still going sir you're still
sticking in there even though I've told
you to bug her off
repeatedly so come on Jay tell everyone
you admitted that all the system Lords
and go all the Dead come on tell
everyone Jay tell everyone Jay come on
right ah Ralph messaged me and said are
the system Lords and the gold the same
and the lari inside the Jaffer yes they
are because they're all the go world
right ah so you're admitting that the
system Lords um so the gold are all dead
so his argument out little Ralphie here
has been arguing that um in Continuum
where bar is killed and they say that is
the end of the system Lords that all the
gold are dead and they cannot
return right and I pointed out to him no
the system law
dead there is still loads of gold world
out there as far as we know there's some
of them on Earth we know about them the
nid tracking them right and we've also
got the ly and all the different planets
that we've seen and also what's what's
the saying about power hates of vacuum
yeah exactly in my in my own series
that's I'm bringing that in okay the
guys you knew G gang gone but there are
a lot of second in command who hey look
at they're stepping up now to try and
you know there's your story ideas ex so
I'm this all came from a video of me
saying that um I wonder if the gold now
headed behind the Lucian Alliance and I
remember I love that that's
a
so it's like saying that the British
government have all been killed so the
rest of the British people are all now
dead it's just not true Ralph and then I
didn't admit that all the system laws
Ser for the gold that you asked me are
they all the same thing I said yes you
went ah I went what like no system Lords
dead they could get new system Lords
right right all that means is it's the
people in power those people in power
apparently are all gone as far as we
know but there's always you
know that I mean that's that's the
openness of to argue about it as silly
because that's first of all we have no
show yet I don't know if you know but we
don't have a freaking show
yet uh so yeah everything's up in the
air until they say different and even
then you know there's going to be people
that go like let's say they come back
with the new show and they
go all the Gould are dead every single
thank God til guys has the serum in him
because he'd be dead too let's say they
do that let's say they do that you know
there'd be people in the world who' go
nope fanfic time here we go and then
start doing their own thing that there's
nothing wrong with that but you know
don't don't ever close down a Poss story
idea yeah
um Ralph I am never mentioning this
again and if you keep commenting I'm
just going to ignore it so please give
up right please does he want them to be
dead is that his thing he wants them to
be I don't know but this is third time
I've brought it up it's I'm not I'm not
doing it again so um I'm right you're
wrong and um yeah basically yeah well
that's a lot how a lot of my videos go
basically when I go I'm right you're
wrong and if somebody go no you're wrong
and I'm like well it's my video
so wrong can I be when it's my channel
um I love it when I occasionally get
videos going ah you shouldn't do videos
like that you should do videos like this
I'm like that's very interesting go do
your own channel right ultimately yeah I
mean that's whatever the [__] I like
because it's my channel well I I
currently I just started paying uh last
week for streamyard because of you and
sorry no no no it's good because it's
cheaper than anybody else and granted
you know I don't make money but I figure
20 bucks a month we'll see how this goes
and so I'm trying to do these live
things wouldn't you know it the last one
I did episode 116 I just mentioned it's
supposed to be live which means like you
it goes hey on YouTube Here's what's
coming up hey on Facebook here's what's
coming up it didn't do it so I had to
record it and then post afterwards so I
didn't get the live feed like you're
getting and like I'm sorry guys you know
I don't know why maybe it's me I could
because it worked the first time when I
did the MacGyver podcast episode the
first time it perfect everything was
live we had someone chiming in second
time I don't know I I have to fuss with
it I guess or complain but uh I think
that's that's the that's the danger
though when you poke the bear on your
video you're going to have people go
and you know argue with you if you're
okay with it that's more power to you I
can't do it I don't mind it to a point
um sometimes it can be very frustrated
but um sometimes you know get a load of
comments it's not a bad thing so here's
a couple of YouTube Secrets here you go
occasionally I will say the wrong name
on
something and um and sometimes it's it's
a genuine mistake but sometimes I do it
on purpose because then I will get a
million comments of people correcting me
and comments are good for the YouTube
algorithm and also sometimes I think
it's funny so um I uh I did it with um
Scott
bacula and and I know because he did an
interview and he said look everyone says
my name wrong and it's bacula like
dracular right and it's quite a famous
video that he did because he he got a
bit wingy about it so I called him buul
which I thought was really funny in my
own brain because I have to amuse myself
um and oh man I got so many comments but
it helps the video and then I get to
comment them going oh it was a joke and
now people still don't get it so um some
people get really angry about these
things you know the YouTube like Sid
trekers don't people that actually
subscribe to me don't they get that I'm
a bit silly and I take kiss
um um I think Ralph does it because he
hasn't taken his medication today
that was so
mean so me sorry yeah I think he just he
just she's just trying to wind me up
um and and I do get a load of people
trying to wind me up on videos and I
sometimes it just annoys me when
somebody will comment something and it
does irritate you and then you um I just
get irritated when I make mistakes I
don't like making mistakes on videos
sure sure but again you're human and
it's a public you know it's like you're
not in any sort of position where you're
going to be held accountable by the
state or something you can just go yeah
I'm human messed up it's my own two
cents sorry kind of thing yeah um the
thing is with me like when I'm doing
videos I do them one of the reasons I
use streamyard is because I can then use
the green screen and I can record
straight away and then I don't have to
um edit in the the background it it can
do it so it saves me loads of times it
sometimes causes me grief because if any
a point the Wi-Fi drops out um it you
can't tell on the edit but then when you
download it it causes this like um
separation of the sound and the picture
so I'm there
going and there's this delay it's really
annoying and it'll only ever happen on a
video if I forget to check that's the
only time it ever happens yeah if I
check it's always perfect I forget check
there's always that [__] delay but
um but the thing with me is I I do
videos fast so something happens I'll
have a video out within half an hour if
I get a chance
um and and and that's I think you guys
know I do like five videos a week um on
science fiction every week I go into it
and I go what the hell am I gonna talk
about this week I always to talk about
um but then then yeah and and and thank
you Carrie have you timed him out of it
Ralph's gone byebye now for a little
while um but yeah we we have very
trusted people like Carri the look after
the channel and basically get rid of the
people putting porn up
oh
yeah you bloody Bots um but you know
like so yes the stream is great and the
other thing that you do one of the
things that you do that I've learned
which is very smart is you'll chop up
chunks of say this conversation to give
little teases so I I did that because
I'm like you know what I don't expect
everybody to sit here for three and a
half hours but there are these moments
that I think are really fun you know so
maybe I'll do little moments that way
it's kind of a tease and you know yeah
and aiming back to the thing I did one
with
um Joe Fagan ages ago that was such a b
it's a it's it's an hour and a half
interview who's got an hour and a half
to sit and listen to an interview but I
can sit and listen to it cut out the
bits I like that are relevant to like
Stargate or something and then talk
about it and it's it's a really
interesting way to do videos I like to
do that when when a um when a video
comes along or when an interview comes
along that that's really interesting um
David blue did one I can't stand David
blue I think he's an absolute idiot um
brilliant actor I like him I love Eli as
a person I find him smarmy and irritated
okay but he did a video I cut out the
bits that I thought were really relevant
and he was actually talking about
something interesting and then you don't
have to watch the rest of the video
right right so happy days as far as I'm
concerned well and also somebody said
you know if you want to get more
attention on your YouTube smaller videos
yeah you know want to do like little
two- minute whatever uh YouTube like 10
minute videos 8 minute videos so if
you're doing a short video it should
always be eight minutes long so this is
I'm I'm giving out all of these the
little hints here you get mid trailers
if it's eight minutes right so then if a
do video does well you're basically
getting another trailer in there so it's
again if you want to make money it's
really good to do but YouTube like it
because you can put and they can put
that extra trailer in they like 8 minute
videos they'll push them more then
you've got to do the shorts but I can't
be asked to do shorts I can't be
bothered you know and that's the problem
unless there's something quick that I
have to say like hey I'm looking for
voice actors for the audio
series um I don't know what I can say in
just a minute or two to go you know
because again like you you get
it these things are stuff that we're
passionate about and we can't say it in
two minutes you have to kind of rant a
little bit to get to your point
yeah exactly um and sometimes talking
for eight minutes can actually be quite
hard when it's something quite little
you're talking about uh one of the
things I get a lot on my videos I always
like oh repeating yourself again you
repeating yourself again and I'm like
yeah but you when I'm doing a video
about a news story and something happens
you do have to sort of tell the story
about where how you got there I have to
do a video based on that you might never
have seen my videos before right so I've
got to explain it but also I'm telling a
narrative I'm trying to explain how you
got there and it does mean I end up
repeat especially my Stargate videos
dear Lord I repeat myself so much on
Stargate videos um but you kind of got
to and then somebody will [__] about it
it's like what but you know what they
are they're the ones that are they're so
familiar with you so they don't need
that repeating part they're already
hooked on you it's you're doing it for
the newbies I get it I'm with you I know
yeah yeah but that that's how I've got
to do it but also like saying I'm
telling a story I could just go Um this
has happened bye yeah it would be a 30
second video but there's
no story you know people go where I
don't believe what this guy's saying
there's no proof so you have to kind of
explain yourself explain it and still
sometimes there's still no proof but I
explain it so hopefully most people
understand that it makes sense like at
the moment um I'm being told basically
that
snargate um it's going to be the summer
now right until we get an announcement
um late spring early summer basically um
and and obviously a lot of people that
they find it so frustrating because it's
like particularly for if you if you've
been watching my channel because I've
been telling you it's oh this this could
be actually this could happen soon and
but I've done that like maybe three
times I think where it looked like it
was going to happen and then for some
reason it hasn't so I've got to explain
now that okay well there's a whole new
problem Amazon have caused for
themselves this causing this delay and
however so again yeah you have to you
have to
explain why something has happened I'm
doing the same with um when I do Star
Trek videos because there there's
there's a lot of business issues going
on at Paramount at the moment so you've
kind of got to explain that to
understand why then something happens
and then um and this will be stuff that
they'll never explain openly Paramount
Amazon are never going to come out and
go yeah we didn't order enough Studio
space sorry that's never going to
happen but the evidence that this is
that I'm I'm you know that I'm telling
you the truth sort of things comes from
the fact that um they've not restarted a
bunch of shows that were in production
before yeah yeah so it's it's two and
two equals four here you know that
that's why it's happening but it's also
why we're not getting announcements on
RoboCop Legally Blonde three which is
what we're all very excited about and
Stargate because they [__] up but you
know and and I know you share this
thought
Sho it's very
frustrating for the last ever since
Amazon bought Stargate 18 months y yeah
uh even way back I mean like we I was
part of that campaign
um where all the Star Trek people were
going hey it's Star Trek let's let them
know that or star yeah Stargate we want
more Stargate give us Stargate you know
let us know you're there let us know
that it's happening and I think by then
Amazon at least MGM should have said
something like all all we wanted was
someone to go we hear you that's all if
they had just said thank you we hear you
and said nothing else we would have been
than good we've been heard but all we
heard was crickets and this is going on
years now I mean years where people are
going I'm not giving you anything I'm
not going to tell you we hear you thanks
not even a thanks for all your effort
yeah and Amazon like you've said I think
on past
posts you they don't care they're not
doing that part of the social yeah
responsibility and they would they would
shine so bright if they just let us know
that they hear us yep they've
only I mean they deadline did that
article in April which basically said
yes we're working on um Stargate RoboCop
and think that is their way of telling
us they're not going to tell us directly
they'll tell us through reporters um and
I remember watching going oh that that
that article didn't mean anything it
didn't mean anything it goes no that is
that has come directly from Amazon if
you don't realize how important that is
sorry it's it's Jackson by the way
Carrie and everybody it's not Johnson
it's Mack Jackson J it's now making sure
they know yeah yeah depends on who you
talk to anyway
uhy
that's
name anyway I saw I watched that Fallout
uh trailer yes oh that was the thing we
were going to talk about an hour ago
yeah um oh I think that might be the
most exciting thing it's it's not going
to be out until the end of 2024 okay um
augusty time uh S Summer 2024 I've never
watched the game I've never played the
game and I think I played the original
which I've suddenly realized was like 25
years ago okay which is like mind blown
I'm so old um it's like 1997 or 1998 or
something like that the first game came
out um so I I I know a bit about the
premise that there's the nuclear war and
um made by the guys that did the the
boys so um it's uh kilter films which is
the main one of the main producers um
and the game the the game creator is
Bethesda which is guys has done the
terrible Stargate game that's coming out
soon yeah I saw that I watched your
video and I'm like yeah it doesn't feel
like Stargate it feels like very dull
and it feels like a very very long
time but maybe maybe it'll it's just the
still the original beta so maybe it'll
it'll it'll come out um apparently
that's my fault his name's Johnson I
don't know what you're talking about
does
know
I I will get people actually saying to
me because um says your name Jamie yes
it is yeah but um is it really
James no Jamie yeah um but what's on
your birth certificate Jamie but is it
short for James
no it's Jamie um my wife's name is Cindy
and she's not Cynthia it's Cindy it's
just
yeah um Jay should run a bll on how
confident we are I don't know how to do
it though so um because we're doing it
through streamyard I can't run a poll I
have to do it through YouTube so I'm
sorry I can't but I will do one on the
Community page after this remind me uh
is the most freaking frustrating thing
in the world if you're a Stargate fan
we've talked about this I'm no matter
what they say no M until I see it on the
screen I'm
like I don't know because same thing
with Quantum Leap I was like oh God
please please don't ruin this please
don't and thank God they did it right
and you know the only thing I'm left
with with with the um Quantum Leap is
the little nitpicky things which I think
we're blessed to have like I'm like okay
if she uses the hand link it should make
the hand link sound when he looks in the
mirror there should be that sound when
he sees his reflection yeah uh and when
you got to remember and you'll
appreciate this the Hologram has limited
space to move around in the Imaging
chamber yeah therefore a go so
every so once in a while you have to
have them reposition themselves Al did
it all the time they did an episode of
season one on on the newno Quantum Leap
where they never showed Addison go
they're out in the woods and she's
walking with him the entire hour I'm
like no no but what if they do a um so
how they get around that in
the hollow deck on Star Trek is that
you're basically walking on a treadmill
but it's not really a treadmill it's
like electromagnetic so you feel like
you're walking but you're actually not
going anywhere see if they would say
that on the show I don't fine good they
never said that in Star Trek before it's
in the Star Trek manual really they
explained in the TNG manual yeah oh
well when they explained how it all
worked um the popcorn power has
suggested I do the thing and I just went
on the Community page because I can do
two things at once look at me so there
is a poll right now on the community p
page will Star Trek will Amazon and I've
just said yes or no by the way I just
will Stargate yeah oh [__] now I better
check I put start you did I know I made
the mistake as we were talking before
I've it I've done it in videos and then
not even caught it on on the
edit um I'm such an idiot uh view
Channel community did I do star I did
starg he all right good um we've had one
vote no
so yeah um well what you answer the
question do you think um my full name is
not Jamie the magic
torch that's that I've just I've just
been thrown back to my childhood there's
a TV show and when I was a when I was a
young boy called Jamie and Jamie in his
magic torch right and he had a torch and
he used to shine on the ground and he
used to open a portal to another world
and he used take his dog and he would go
into this other world and it was and it
was a kid show it was a cartoon kid show
and the theme tune was Jamie Jamie Jamie
and his magic T it was awesome um and
obviously I was the only Jamie so I got
nothing but but obviously when we were
about eight nobody knew the the the
penis jokes that you could have had with
Jamie is go on the show she magic Torch
Mate um and I'm like it is
Magic um and so um but I got so much
crap for it and I still get occasionally
people will send me oh my god did you
know this just TV show called Jam's
magic torch yes did you know it looks
just like you yes I Jackson remember
there was a movie Action Jackson I'm
like no I'll take it that's fine just I
will get you a Jam's magic torch thing
and the the character had blue eyes I
have blue eyes um but I used to have big
moppy um thick
hair sort thing
um be a to see it very well but okay
sure yeah that was
me at that age a 100% that was
me so you asking if I think Amazon's
gonna do a good
job yeah yeah that's what you
think um it's on sorry just a second
it's on the Community
page for me I don't know I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna poo poo it like everybody
in on the internet does it's gonna be be
garbage okay then it probably will be
with that kind of attitude I just I pray
to God the right people we've talked
about this and you've done videos about
it and it comes down to the people in
charge knowing
understanding what it is knowing why it
works and then taking their ego out of
it if we can have that magic
formula there's no reason why it
shouldn't be great you know without
getting into all the details that we did
before
it it can it can it depending on who's
in charge it can go one way very hard or
the other way very hard I don't think
it's kind of gonna do one of these where
some of it's good some of it's bad I
think and I pray it'll go really well
maybe there's a little things you and I
will nitpick you know maybe maybe we'd
like it to be back in the same Mountain
Cheyenne Mountain whatever if they do
great if they don't as long as they
explain it and it doesn't feel foreign
like you know for me season 9 and 10
didn't need to feel foreign they could
have just kept on keeping on but they
tried too much to go no we're doing a
different show and it yanked me out of
it too much and that's not just because
RDA wasn't there it was a lot of other
things for every every episode had a
moment where I went no right there that
moment would not have happened in the
previous Seasons so with this new show
I'm just I I can't even give an opinion
I just pray I'm I'm praying they do it
and they're sincere but you and I have
had a lifetime of shows where we watched
second seasons of shows go to crap
because somebody's ego got involved I
wanted to make sure people knew people
knew I did this look at I'm the new
showrunner you need to know it's me yeah
but you just destroyed the show yeah you
know my wife and I ideas as well
sometimes shows they just run out of
ideas right I
mean with Stargate I mean Stargate is so
open they should never run out of ideas
but there are others where you go well
we had a great idea for a first season
what do you do with the second season
well we didn't plan that far ahead why
like this Fallout show that that we
we're trying to get to and talk about I
don't know it I don't know much about I
know it was a video game but you know
what based on that trailer I see a world
of opportunities
there's no reason this should not work
you know I say I think for's going to be
awesome I think they've got a really
good team I just worry that it might be
a bit Boise and and they might try and
shock us because it is a violent video
game sure post nuclear war loads of um
mutants and things and but um I think
it'll be laugh a minute if if they do it
right and they get the tone right and
they don't start at 100 miles an hour I
want them to give us somewhere with the
Stargate thing
though 100% depends who they've got in
charge they get the right people in
charge will get a brilliant show Amazon
proved that they they can make brilliant
Telly because what they tend to do is
they just tend to get people they they
put someone in charge and they leave
them to it they don't tend to interfere
too much which is one of the problems of
rings of power they didn't they have
done for the second series apparently
Executives have got way more involved in
sort of going look we need this this and
this come on this has got to be better
um we're spending a billion quid on this
for God's
sake um but generally speaking they
don't do that they let creators crack on
so if they pick the right creators which
they didn't do for rings of power I'm
sorry they just didn't um we'll get a
great show I have heard something
concrete about Mark Fergus still being
involved or at very least he was um in
June um but the strikes have sort of had
a bit of a we've had an unknown quality
there because of the strikes thankfully
thanks
thanks um
so you know I'm not going to definitely
100% say they're still involved but they
were in June so um and I think they're
the right people I think penguin and
Parker can do this I know they've
already got another show with Amazon
they're doing as well one of the
Warhammer or Warhammer or the other one
there's two the very similar titles
games turning into [__] TV series of
Doom um but um which they are developing
still at the moment but that's gone to
production now so they can move on but
also they're production company they can
do two or three different shows at once
it's not a problem um so um I'm hoping
it's still going to be those guys um
whether they'll do a good job or not I
think those guys could do a good job and
like you said if they keep it simple
people simple
stupid my problem with Atlantis was I
thought Atlantis should have gone for
another at at least another two seasons
I was good at it didn't SGU I actually
think though they were limiting
themselves they weren't they didn't have
a lot of places to go with that show
don't get me wrong I wanted it to end I
wanted a conclusion I wanted two or
three more seasons and what have you but
it would have worked I think SGU would
have worked better as a streaming Series
where we only got 10 episodes a year um
and I think it would have been so much
better um you know like 40 or 50
episodes god of war thank you Dave I'm
Warhammer and God of War I keep mixing
them up
um so
um it's a shame almost it was a bit too
early it's a shame really SGU didn't
come maybe like two or three years later
because it would have been extrem in
show and I think I just think I just the
way the show was I think it would have
worked better yeah I think I think well
we all know there were so many factors
that that made that not work but before
even the network issues happened they
shot themselves in the foot cuz they got
rid of Atlantis for SGU no matter what
they say that's clearly what they did
and so people who liked Atlanta went hey
oh hey hey no you didn't give us a
conclusion what the heck and the other
part of it was they made the mistake of
saying if you like battl Star Galactica
that's what we're doing
no we love Battlestar Galactica because
it's Battlestar Galactica don't mess
with our SG universe okay I I accepted
it I loved it I I didn't need it I
didn't need it to do it the way that
they did it but it was still connected
to my Stargate I still got to see Jack I
still got you know to know that it was
part of this world and it's whatever I'm
much more forgiving about certain things
but I knew the moment they said that
people checked out before the first
episode aired yeah so that plus
everything else I mean you have to
relish the formula that they have you
know and also be respectful like like
John's saying they they need to conclude
it because you have to respect the
audience I love even if I'm not watching
a show or I don't like the show I always
respect the fact that the network went
you know what we're ending it but we are
gonna let you wrap it up that's all you
want that's really all you want at the
end of the day yep yep I say I actually
think unseen censor said um admittedly I
I liked Atlantis a lot loved University
yet me older I only watch SGU
religiously SG religiously me too um I I
actually think Atlantis is the slightly
better show I know it's funny that you
that you're you're you're quite the
unique duck for that yeah I I have a
problem with it if if I hadn't seen sg1
and I watched Atlantis and then watched
sg1 I think I'd have been the right so
sg1 is the daddy sg1 is the best show
it's the best characters it is way it's
it's it's it's a it's it's my favorite
show ever made right but I actually but
if I think Atlantis had come first I
think I'd be sitting there going
Atlantis is the best show it's it's my
favorite show it's the best show ever
may but it
came I wonder see for me I always look
at I always call Atlantis the little
brother of sg1 it's you know it's it's
its own thing but the the world will
always look at it as yeah you're doing
great you know your brother though
however your older brother you know so
when you have Perfection and you do the
offshoot doesn't matter how good this
guy does you're always going to be
thinking
about that and the fact that by that
point Robert Cooper had taken control
over sg1 yeah and Atlantis and what he
brought was the things that RDA fought
against which was cliche characters and
cliche moments yeah and as much as I
love uh
um Jason Mamoa as a person
I hated Ronan Dex I hated Vala I hate
anybody who is the oh you're filling
that that cliche you know I need the big
tough guy or I need the the [__]
little space girl who's
sassy I you know I remember when that
came about I just
went
oh so we're doing that now okay and I
was always I had a problem with the fact
that they got rid of rainbow Sun
Franks and they they even said it we we
got rid of him to bring in Ronan Dex
yeah you didn't have to get rid of one
to get the other you could have had both
no they could have but um uh and I don't
agree with you with Ron next thing
because I think um Jason M MO is just he
was brilliant yeah oh yeah he's great
yeah completely get that the um the
characters are they basically said right
we've got to have an O'Neal character
we've got to have a Daniel Jackson type
character we've got to have a teal kind
of character that because we've got a
formula for how this show works and when
they did you they just went we are we're
not following that formula anymore and
that's why I think some people turned
off it initially I I turned off it
because I I found it boring they took
the humor out that was my biggest
problem with it and they dragged it
dragged you SGU first few episodes air
and whatever water you're just like get
to it come on you're asking a lot of
your audience now let's yeah you know
the first two episodes of SGU are
phenomenal though the third episode is
when they kick in and you go H and then
it's every episode is like that then for
about half a season and it's very dreary
very slow but it was getting better and
and I think somebody said in the
comments earlier it was beautifully made
it was the best made of all of them yeah
um from a like a production point of
view um it was just it was just I just
found it boring but oh my God it was
getting better and at the end of the day
even boring Stargate is still better
than 9% of the other stuff I'm telling
do you know did I tell you what Jason
Mamoa wanted to do with his character he
was one of those guys who his idea for
Ronan was better than what they gave him
he was like okay Rona needs to have some
sort of drama angst happen to him and at
one point he because he's like a
Manchild decided to cut his hair and
that ticked them all off because like oh
who whoa continuity we need to you know
so they glued the thing back onto his
head yeah we right the last season yeah
so what his thing was he also came back
with the tattoo and they're like dude
you play ball with us here come on yeah
so what he wanted them to do a couple
thoughts um I don't remember all of them
but I remember loving every idea that he
had and one of them was for him to get
captured and do an arc where he's
getting tortured and one of the thing
was to have live them cutting his
hair like he he he brought that up he's
like what if like because his hair was
so important to him it meant so much and
he'd be like tortured be ah you know
like that or maybe they scar his arm too
and that's why he had to do the tattoo
and they said no no so that last
season he was really like ticked and I
think that was his way of rebelling and
they went yeah well you're wearing a wig
you know and they made him wear the wig
for the rest of the season but his
ideas I'm like yeah you I like it you
you made you gave you gave that one note
character more depth more layers which I
really would have loved because then he
wouldn't just be the wook you
know
yeah I love there was an argument
between him and David huet and David
huet says he can't even remember what it
was about but that was in the period
where he was getting
um um Jason Mamo was getting quite
pissed off with the character he like he
said he didn't really feel like it was
going anywhere yeah um but also Jas Mamo
is very clear by fact that he was
partying maybe a little bit too much um
but him and um but him and David hulet
basically didn't talk for years after
and I see David huet talking in an
interview about it because he's is he
was getting in Jason mimo's face
screaming at him having a you know I
then it just halfway through I realized
oh he's
bigy I guess for some reason but he said
I'd committed myself I was like I've
committed myself at this point so I
couldn't back
down oh he's
big well it's funny fulet always is very
much I think like Rodney I mean he said
it himself yeah I'm without the smarts
I'm I'm I'm that Sassy attitude Rodney
guy like yeah it you know great
actor I uh I very clever guy I met his
sister uh oh really yeah yeah well I
used to before Mikey was born I used to
Cindy and I would always go to the New
Jersey Stargate convention ah Co yeah
and and it was great because I got to
long story short I met Jason Mamoa twice
he remembered me performing at the con
uh the first year and he said hey next
time I'll bring my guitar we could Jam
well the next time I saw him I brought
my guitar and he went
oh and and you know he it was one of
those where they all come around to the
table and they sit with you for a few
minutes and you all get to talk and
shoot the ball well when that was
over he gets up and uh I guess ran and
got goes dude I
hear down the hall and he goes he has
the slide dude go get your guitar I'm
like oh okay so we spent two hours
trading my guitar back and forth playing
songs he taught me how to play the slide
I showed him how to play certain bar
chords and and then he goes you know
what we ought to do we ought to go get a
guitar you want to go get a
guitar okay well they yank him off
because they have to feed him by
contract and they they're trying to hide
him from me and he not that I'm I'm I
just like okay we're gonna go get a
guitar together the guy goes I find him
and he's in there finishing up he goes
hey back two seconds I'm like okay guy
comes up you know how the handlers who
are supposed to be volunteering at these
conventions they get a little ego going
instead of being helpful they're all
about no nobody's getting by that guy
except me well they go what do you doing
not then we're just going to go get get
a guitar he goes no I said no we are
goes I can't have you in the car with
them it's a legal issue I said okay just
tell me where you're gonna go I'll drive
my own car no I said okay well now
you're being an
a-hole so long story short he goes gets
a guitar on his own finds me again while
I'm watching somebody's panel and go and
goes hey we spent another two hours
playing guitar in the lobby there's
pictures on our on our Facebook pages of
that it was such a great because now it
wasn't about a star and a guy who
watches the show he remembered me as a
musician you're my musician Buddy I'm
like Okie doie and at the time his wife
and my wife were just about ready to
give birth to our sons so we're bonding
over that and it's great but anyway uh
Rodney mccay's or um his the sister was
there at the convention and so was um uh
the Scottish um give me his name oh um
yeah uh Becket but I can't remember your
name yeah yeah so he's there and we're
talking to him one night and he the
other thing a lot of these people do
that are supposed to be volunteering is
they try and take advantage of the star
so they're trying to get him drunk so
they just kept refilling his drink when
he wasn't looking so he's feeling no
pain and I'm talking to him and he's f
fasinated with me and Cindy you're
married and a Scottish accent really
comes out oh you guys are great well now
we think I don't we've talked for a
while I'm gonna end it and let him get
on with this night I said well I'll talk
to you later buddy he goes all right
come here beautiful and he gives me this
big
kiss on the side of the face which I
understand it's a loving
sweet thing it's not you know it's not
Paul mcgillian thank you uh of course
when I need to remember it I can't no no
no of course we're live you brain us on
other things yeah so Paul M Gillan gives
me this big kiss and I think isn't that
sweet because I I get it it's it's not a
goofy thing to be made fun of however
the people at the rest of the table when
I turned around didn't get that memo
yeah and they teased me merciful Lesly
for the rest of the weekend like oh yeah
oh give how about I give you a kiss
we're on the elevator with with her
uh McKay's sister and we're want to say
Jennifer but I don't think that's right
no um somebody will will'll jump on I
reading about it literally the other day
um literally two days
ago anyway uh so anyway she she's we're
riding in the elevator with her and
people are teasing me going oh how's
your boyfriend Paul mcgillian give you a
little kissing Kate thank you Kate huet
Kate huet is her name so Kate's there
and as she's getting off the elevator to
go her own way and we're all laughing
and she's laughing at me because I'm
like all right guys I got it let's be
mature and like she goes or somebody
goes yeah he gave you a big sloppy kiss
and as she gets off the elevator she
turns and goes I'd give you a kiss too
and she walks away everybody on the
other is
like that works all right that all right
not a bad thing I
guess a very pretty lady so what you
we're gonna have to we Are Gonna wind up
yeah we really should yeah it's been an
hour and a half and man united are
playing in half hour and I have to go
watch Doctor Who apparently because I
forgot it was on so let's just have a
quick look at will um Amazon ruin
Stargate if I can get my page to
refresh go to another one and then come
back again um let only had one vote
surely only had one
vote give it time
uh I don't I don't I don't believe it I
think it's just I don't think it's um go
how do you oh they keep changing the
[__] fange yeah I don't why you just
why do you hate me so much right so
there's been 38 votes um 53% say no will
Amazon MGM produce good Stargate no 53%
47% say yes they will that 38 votes so
far it's been let's remember we got to
be positive otherwise nothing happens
and then they'll they'll take it away
from us well Legion says it when I woke
they make it which is everyone's go to
which hopefully we're getting past that
as a society though like let's you know
what I mean that pendulum hope swinging
back the studios are I I honestly think
the studios at the moment they're
realizing that there's a worse thing to
be called than racist sexist anything
else is is being called woke and it's a
death nail so uh
um yeah I I think there is I think
there's going to be a move away from
executiv stressing quite so much bad and
we know this is happening because Disney
and a few others they started hiring
inclusion Executives sure um almost all
of them have been sacked now and they've
moved start to move away from it so you
did your job you proved your point
you're gone yeah yeah yeah we we've got
yeah we just did a a Shakespeare with um
and not a single person was the same
from the same country well done um
that's um we just did Henry VII where it
was a I don't know I'm gonna stop that
thing because I'm
gon but um um but but yeah it's
definitely been one of the things about
um Chris Carter was talking about
bringing back the X Files um and
potentially doing a um a new series
which would be a continuation but with
new characters so soft reboot something
with the xiles and the first thing he
said was it's going to be more inclusive
so I'm like that's great but why is that
the first thing that you yeah yeah yeah
and and fair enough there's only two
characters really the starred in The X
Files sure one's a man one's a woman
okay neither of them are a you
know African-American whatever but you
know you can have two people at work and
have a
reasonable chance that they would both
be white or both black or both whatever
it don't matter if you had a cast of 100
and they were all white I'd beat going
this is set in Louisiana I'm not sure
all you people should be white right
fair enough um
but um I I just I just found it very
strange that that was the first thing I
mean and I'm not even joking he
basically said we're bringing back the
xile it's going to be more
inclusive and I'm like you haven't even
started writing it yet you haven't done
anything yet why is that the first thing
in the press release to say that we're
going to do this the first thing you
have to say and that just screamed at me
that executives are gone you're going to
have to tell people because that we keep
getting accused of being pink skinned
instead well you know it reminds me of
the joke that they make about let's say
vegetarians yeah you know you know why
they're a
vegetarian or you know how you know how
you could tell that they're a vegetarian
why because they won't shut up about it
yep you don't have just just yeah let
quality be your guide you don't need to
tell
everybody your internal agenda just make
good TV you don't have to tell us if
it's woke or if it's inclusive just make
it just make it good and we'll go okay
Quantum Leap perfect example this new
cast very diverse very diverse but
they're not going did you notice how
diverse we are no they're they're
wearing lipstick he's wearing lipstick
just move on he's a person or they're
they are a person you don't need to go
we're putting up a billboard so that
people watch Quantum Le because it's so
inclusive
no just make good TV and then people
will accept it but if you start with
that Banner of X Files is going to be
you know diverse well okay great it
should have been anyway if you're gonna
do something just do it I think there's
a big woke bear out there and Chris
Carter was just poking it with the stick
screen woke at
me car I could just admitted Disney has
been terrible um yeah
it's Disney has been Disney have
basically admitted they're in a complete
rebuild well because they got they got
lazy they went oh you love Marvel you
love Star Wars great basically they do
what I always say the Beatles did the
Beatles went and they even admitted it
Paul said it we knew whatever we were
going to do people were GNA buy so we
could just either try or not and I think
Disney did that kind of thing where they
went whatever just make whatever you
want we'll slap Mar on it and people
will dig it
and people went no no no we kind of we
want a certain quality and you know like
I remember you going on about we'll just
do it quickly yeah or we'll just do it
really fast think I think of you with
She-Hulk right I enjoyed most of
She-Hulk except for the last episode
where know you know about the comic you
have you ever read the comic I've read
bits of the comic I'm not it was not in
my favorite I know she broke
in the comic as well exactly so that
they made the mistake of going we're
going to do what we do in the comic
however that doesn't translate as well
in live action because live action is
more concrete to people than a comic
story which could be ignored two issues
later if you do this on a live a TV show
you go that's part of the MCU now so the
moment that she walks around and talks
to the executives and we never see an
actual fight wrap up to
what all these episodes were you just
ticked off the audience hey they spent
six episodes Building up to something
they just went nah but I felt like with
um shehulk they basically they went if
you like this stuff you're an idiot and
I'm like whoa whoa whoa so I'm so
basically went to all the Marvel fans
you're all stupid if you like this do
you want you know they have the whole
fight bit at the end because does this
is this helping anyone does this is this
what we should do or should we do
something different I'm like no I want
to see the fight I want to see the
fight see the fight right right and for
me I mean I I love Daredevil so the
moment I saw him I'm like all right give
me more Daredevil and then they do that
last episode you're like wow you're not
cute that didn't work that no that that
wasn't cute at all again with dead Devil
with Deadpool sorry they they're going
too
far and there's a lot of the um fourth
wall stuff which is like She-Hulk and
like pool I never liked him I didn't
like him as a character I think Ryan
Reynolds is great as a character
I aren't I cute look at me I'm talking
right to you I hate that I that's not
for me Daredevil was though Daredevil
was the best thing in shehulk but even
that was basically
undone like say did it happen or not we
don't really know but I was just think I
just and I that was my main problem with
shehulk it just felt like they were sort
of going if you like this sort of thing
and you like Marvel then you're then
there's something wrong with you or
you're an idiot or
and and we can be clever we can do
better than this can't we I'm like no I
want to
see the Hulk get punched in the face by
shehulk right do it right um and that
guy that looks a bit like um Dave Gro
from um the food Fighters when he was
younger I want to see him get punched in
the face as well absolutely but you you
want so well I don't know if you heard
this latest rumor they're apparently
quietly giving us moonnight She-Hulk and
Miss Marvel season two okay great great
with with with moonnight the last
episode ticked me off because it it
didn't like make sense I blinked and
then looked up and then there was a
hippotamus talking to me and that was at
the point I realized I hadn't really
been watching that show I knew right no
bloody clue what was going on so maybe
these second seasons will redeem those
two shows I I enjoyed Miss Marvel a
great deal um my understanding is i'
I've have us talk to somebody that's
doing um um as know somebody that's that
has been working on the sheel they are
in the they are in the writers room now
doing it um and they have a list of
requirements from um specifically from
Kevin F of what it can be and they have
basically been told it's got to fit
within the universe again it cannot be
because if you're going to do a comedy
show do a comedy show or do a Marvel
show you cannot do what we did last time
it was too
confusing it needs to be one thing so
the basically the writers have been told
you you need to tell us what show you're
doing and then you need to stick to that
if you want to do a comedy show that's
going to break the fourth wall and take
the piss that's fine but that's what it
needs to be right do not Chop and change
and and if that's
true so yeah I pray to God it is because
again people want more just give them
better that's all don't get lazy don't
get don't get well you're just GNA buy
anything we make no we won't no a secret
Invasion do we talk about secret
Invasion wow that was that useless show
ever made rubbish right I find it very
hard to like I'm supposed to care about
random green guys who don't like each
other um I didn't remember you much from
from Captain Marvel the first movie now
you're giving me a series on you all
final episode I'm watching my
five-year-old son and he there going
that's not how DNA works
I know I know a child who doesn't even
know what DNA is and even you know
that's not how DNA works well done how
come um he's got you know a genetically
engineered thing but it's all the it's
covered in the tattoos of the character
that's so that you know that that is arm
is supposed to be dracs the Destroyer
because you how come tattoo to tattoos
is genetic no right very good I I knew
that I'm like yes I know you knew that
son because you're not a [__]
[__] writers are that wasn't that
wasn't the payoff like that's supposed
to make us all happy I'm like you made a
super scroll and you made it a girl
whatever I I don't super scroll is like
a a a z-level character like who cares
it's random it doesn't matter and now
you made that be the big payoff I don't
I didn't care all the way through and
even even uh uh Fury didn't feel like
Fury no F like a grumpy old man guys we
have to call it an evening because I
need a we weirdly ah um that's basically
how all of my live streams end when my
bladder goes you're ending now so we
have to end Mac it's been a brilliant to
get you back um we will have you back
very shortly um because we always have a
good chat we always I'm telling you
there's a list of things we haven't even
touched on yet so anytime and we will we
will we will touch each other every
chance we get
to oh you sent you a Catholic earlier so
I assumed you into that sort thing no no
no no not that kind of Catholic no no
I'm Al I'm also Cath
so I am into that sort um right then
well I was I went to a Catholic school I
will make an appointment on my phone
then ma Johnson
baby
Jackson Johnson Johnson you're not
you're not helping my my my YouTube
channel at all they that everybody now
immediately search for Mac Johnson on
YouTube guys the links are in the
description to go and see more of ma and
his show he puts way more work into than
I do uh and put to mine so um really
really great thank you so much
um we'll see you again really soon
bud this video has to end very
quickly we'll be back tomorrow live as
usual an hour earlier at Harris's
request because he's off doing something
young people do so um rich thank you
guys unseen Center thank you Oliver
brain pain thank you kry everybody in
really really appreciate it we'll see
you
soon uh I forgot to do the brand thing
I'll just end
by